امس قال الماسك شارك عن بعد في القمه
العالميه للحكومات في دبي واتكلم عن
التكنولوجيا والتعليم والعمل واكيد كان
لازم طبعا يتكلم عن منصه تويتر اللي من
وقت ما صار مالكها ورئيسها وهو قالبها
راسا على عقب قرارات وجدل واستطلاعات رايي
واقالات واستقالات افلام يعني ففي الاول
ماسك اتكلم عن اهميه تويتر واهميه انه
الناس والمسؤولين يعبروا وينشروا تغريدات
وينقلوا رسالتهم اللي حابين يوصلوها للناس
عن طريق المنصه وانه يكتبوا هذه الرسائل
بنفسهم مو عن طريق مثلا شخص او فريق او ما
الى ذلك واتكلم كمان عن المنافسه مع
المنصات الثانيه وكمان عن تعرضوا الدائم
للانتقادات وكونوا دائما في موقع هجوم من
الناس عليه ماسك في القمه انسال كمان متى
راح يعين رئيس جديد لتويتر كونه هو بنفسه
ديسمبر قال انه بيراس تويتر مؤقتا وراح
يستقيل بيبحث عن شخص مجنون بما في الكفايه
ليستلم عنه الوظيفه واصلا هذا الاعلان كان
اعلنوا من بعد من بعد ما عمل استفتاء
قبلها بايام وعد بالالتزام بنتيجته وسال
الناس هل اتنحى عن رئاسه تويتر وقتها اكثر
من 17 مليون شخص صوتوا في هذا الاستفتاء
والنتيجه كانت 57% ونص صوت وقالوا نعم
بالعوده لقمه الحكومات مصر ان سال عن
وعوده بالتنحي عن الرئاسه ومتنوعين رئيس
جديد وهذا كان رده
كويس
[موسيقى]
على تويتر بانه يبدو انه خلاص اللي مجنون
كفايه عشان يكون سيد تويتر الجديد وكشف عن
هويته في سلسله تغريدات الرئيس الجديد هو
كلبه فنشر ايلون ماسك تغريده عليها كذا
فيها صوره لكلبه وهو جالس ورا المكتب في
تويتر ولابس تيشيرت مكتوب عليها سي اي او
وامامه اوراق وعنوان التغريده الرئيس
التنفيذي الجديد لتويتر رائع وكمل بتغريده
الثانيه قال فيها الرئيس الجديد هذا افضل
بكثير من هذاك الثاني هذه التويتر عاد
ملغومه صار في جدل في فهمها يعني كويس هل
هو يقصد انه الكلب افضل منه هو شخصيا ولا
افضل من الرئيس التنفيذي السابق براج
اجروال اللي طلعوا
ما وقف مديح في فلوكي مكمل ونشر سيل من
التغريدات عن مميزات الرئيس الجديد فقال
انه
رهيب في كل ما الارقام والحسابات وفي
تغريده ثانيه قال انه كمان عنده ستايل نار
ومن بعدها بدا الاخذ والرد ففي حساب كتب
لمسك يبدو انك ما لقيت مجنون كفايه يرقص
تويتر غيره ورد
مثالي للوظيفه وفي حساب ثاني صخر من
تغريدات ماسك بتخيل لاعضاء مجلس اداره
تجاره الجديد فحط صوره ماسك وفلوكي وابن
ماسك الاصغر اللي هو اسمه هذا اكس اللي
كان كده اسمه معادله
واختصروها باكس ويبدو ان النكته عجبت مره
ماسك لانه رد عليها بايموجي واعمل لها
كمان ريتويت
[موسيقى]